- [Voiceover] If p and n are integers
such that p is greater than
n, is greater than zero.
So this tells us since p
is strictly greater than n
that means that they're
two different integers.
p is larger of these
two different integers
and that they're both positive.
They're both greater than zero
and they tell us that p
squared minus n squared
is equal to 12.
p squared minus n squared is equal to 12.
Which of the following can
be the value of p minus,
the value of p minus n?
So one thing that might
jump immediately out of use
and you could factor p
squared minus n squared,
that this is a difference of squares.
And why it especially jumps out this,
when you factor it, one of
the factors is p minus n.
So this could be factored as p plus n,
times p minus n.
This is just factoring
a difference of squares,
is equal to 12.
Is equal to 12.
Now, what we essentially have
is a product of two
expressions is equal to 12
but each of expressions,
this expression right over here, p plus n,
this is the sum of two positive integers.
This is a difference of
two positive integers
so both of these are going to be positive.
Both of these are positive integers.
The reason why we know p
minus n is a positive integer
is they tell us that p is greater than n.
So this is going to be a positive value.
So let's think about all
the different combinations
of positive integers that
we could take their product
and get to 12.
So, it could be and this of course,
this of course is going
to be larger of the two.
This is going to be the larger of the two
and this is going to be the smaller.
Smaller of the two.
So let's see.
You could have 12 times one.
12 times one is definitely equal to 12.
You could have, let's see.
You could have six times
two which is equal to 12.
You could have four times three
which is also equal to 12.
So these are essentially
all of the contenders
for p plus n and p minus n.
So let's think about how
we can rule some of these,
some of these scenarios.
Some of these scenarios out.
So let's take the first scenario.
Let's say that p plus n.
p, let me write it in green.
So the first scenario.
Let's say that p plus n is equal to 12
and p minus n is equal to one.
p minus n is equal to one.
Well, we could solve for p here.
We could add the left hand side.
It's the left hand side
as the n is canceled out.
You're left with two p.
And you add the right hand side.
You get 13, p.
You divide both sides by two,
you get p is equal to 13 over two.
Now, this is not cool
because this contradicts
one of our first assumptions
that p needs to be an integer.
This right over here is not an integer.
So, p plus n could not be 12
and p minus n cannot be one.
So, p minus n cannot be one.
So actually we can rule
this out right over here.
p minus n cannot be one.
Now let's think about this scenario
where p plus n is equal to six.
p plus n is equal to six.
That's the larger of the two factors.
And p minus n is equal to two.
Well, same idea.
We can add the left hand side.
We go off with two p
and then the right hand side,
we get six plus two is equal to eight.
Divide both sides by two,
you get p is equal to four.
And if p is equal to four then you see,
well, see four plus what is equal to six?
Well, four plus two is equal to six
and is equal to two.
And that works out here.
Four minus two is equal to two.
So, this is completely consistent.
Both of these are positive integers.
They're different positive integers,
p is greater than n.
So it's completely possible that p minus n
is equal to two.
So, this is completely a
possible value of p minus n.
And then let's look at this last.
So this one works out.
Let's look at this last scenario.
So we have p plus n is equal to four
and p minus n is equal to three.
Well, same idea.
The left hand side you get
two p is equal to seven.
Well once again, we
divide both sides by two.
p is equal to 7/2.
This is not an integer.
Just like here, this cannot be the case
because p needs to be an integer.
In this case, p is being forced.
If p plus n was four
and p minus n is three
then you are not going to have,
then p is not going to be an integer.
So this is also not a possibility.
Now, we could have ruled this out
even without doing that exercise
because if p minus n was four,
if p minus n was four,
then p plus n would have to be three.
But p plus n is going to be
the larger of the two values.
So, p minus n even if this
were a possible scenario,
even if we didn't end up with
a non-integer right over here,
we could have gotten p minus
n to three but not to four.
p minus n is going to be the
lesser of the two factors
between if four and three
were even contenders.
But we know here that they aren't.
But anyway, we could rule that one.
We can rule that one out as well.
So the only possible value of p minus n
or which of the following
can be a value of p minus n?
Two.